welcome everyone thanks for joining us
i trust that you have enjoyed the first
few videos that we have made available
lately which is part of what we are
thinking of as a a year-long version of
the world science festival programming
much of it online so we had does math
reveal reality we had our language
program mind your language and indeed it
was one of you in the audience who named
that program so thank you very much we
also had the live conversation
with max tegmark in which a number of
your questions about math and reality we
pushed it a little bit forward in that
one-on-one conversation
it has been an exciting
week for science i trust that many of
you are following the news
this is the nobel prize week where new
nobel laureates are being announced and
indeed we are going to have a series of
conversations with some of the newly
minted laureates
in the coming weeks and indeed that's
what we are doing here today
and just to get us into the subject for
today's conversation look i think we've
all
not i think i know that we all have the
experience
of engaging with the world with our
senses touching something it's hot or
it's cold or eating something that's
spicy we can feel it or or perhaps
overeating and and feeling the effects
of that within our bodies and and and
one of the deep questions that
scientists have struggled with over the
course of many decades is
how do we do that
what is
the molecular machinery
by which the human body is able to
sense the environment with such
precision and nuance can we
reduce those physical processes to
molecular motions that are responsible
for
the sensations that
we all have and on monday
the nobel prize in physiology or
medicine was announced for two
scientists whose work has spectacularly
advanced our understanding
in that arena of science that arena of
questioning david julius and artem
potapudian
and we are thrilled to have a
conversation with both of the scientists
here today
i'm going to begin
with david julius who joins us from his
home
outside of san francisco so david
welcome thank you for joining us
thank you brian pleasure to be here and
and again you know enormous
congratulations on this award we'll get
into the science in just a second but i
sort of can't resist
asking you you know what was it like to
get you know that that phone call early
in the morning your time uh you know
it's um
you hear about this from other people
who've gotten nobel prize and you just
got you know it's always interesting and
fun to read when it happens to you it's
still a bit of an out-of-body experience
and uh yeah it was quite thrilling and
um you know things start happening at
two in the morning at least west coast
time and then you know everything breaks
loose from there so you don't really get
back to bed or anything for quite a long
time yeah and um you know i have to say
that um the nobel prize is still
sort of the preeminent prize that's
recognized around the world and it
brings in so much attention
uh you know and and
at that level it is wonderful to see how
interested people still are in science
and what's happening in terms of
scientific advances it's really
i think that's the most miraculous and
wonderful thing about prizes and about
the nobel in particular is that it does
at least for a week focused a lot of
people's attention on recent advances or
well advances that happened a while ago
but you know recent description of those
advances to the public uh to everybody
so that they can really kind of connect
with science yeah
it's enormously
exciting and and i agree with you one of
the things that
keeps me going gets me up in the morning
is the fact that
in an an arena and in a world in which
we
know that there's a lot of backlash
against expertise in science and
scientists the fact that there is
a deep
interest in the kinds of work that's
being done at the frontier is of course
gratifying to all of us who who are
engaged in the pursuit of knowledge so
maybe we can
jump in
to
the work of yours that was awarded with
the nobel prize
so so your your interest is
understanding how
the body senses things like heat
and cold um where where did that
interest come from was it sort of as a
kid you were thinking about that or is
this something that happened a week
later in your career
yeah during my career you know so when i
was in
an undergraduate in graduate school of
course i worked in laboratories
particularly as a graduate student and
you know in those days i worked on very
different things than what this prize is
about and that what we've worked on
since i've had my own lab
they're also fascinating you know i
think pieces of biology but you know
that training then led up to what i i've
done since i've had my own lab
and
when i started my own lab i uh and when
i actually did my post doctoral training
before that i became interested in the
nervous system
and you know in particular one of the
things that really got me interested
about the nervous system was
um
understanding how
uh natural products affect our behavior
and our nervous system and so when i was
a graduate student
uh i started thinking about um you know
how do things like hallucinogens work
and why do people use
thing uh you know extracts from peyote
and other
uh plant products for ritualistic um you
know ceremonies and you know how do
humans discover these things and then
how do they exploit them either for you
know culinary purposes or for you know
ritualistic purposes
and then of course
uh how do scientists
then
use this kind of um you know uh
folk medicine type information
to mine the active ingredients in these
things and then use them to really tap
into important
signaling processes in the brain and the
spinal cord and other places and i
really got fascinated by that
intersection of sort of it's kind of
like chemical anthropology and science
and um and so that sort of has carried
through since i've had my own lab and uh
and and and that sort of intersected
with my growing interest in
understanding sensory systems in general
but can i jump in because i can't resist
asking what was all that was happening
in like the 60s and early
was that at all well
i i sometimes tell the story which is a
true one that when i was a graduate
student i i did i worked in in some
wonderful labs i did use genetics and
biochemistry and that meant late one
night i was waiting for this huge vat
this fermenter vat of of yeast to come
to the right you know cultured the right
density to mature and so i was just sort
of killing some time lying on a bench
outside the biochemistry building in
berkeley and these two guys walked up to
me it must have been close to midnight
and they said hey man about uh 10 years
ago you know
we got some incredible lsd from somebody
in this building and uh i think some uh
entrepreneurial chemists have been
synthesizing some of that stuff um
probably when it was still legal and uh
and and they said is there any more
around
and i thought you know these guys if
these denizens of berkeley have been
wandering around probably for a decade
you know thinking of of of this as their
primary goal and then i started thinking
about wow you know what this stuff
really has a quite a profound effect on
people's behavior
walter white man this could have been
yeah the beginning of the exact career
right
so so that really did get me intrigued
and uh and i was about about to um you
know wrap up my phd and wonder what i
was going to do in the future and so i
started reading all these books and
papers by great scientists like saul
snyder
and uh and again george again who worked
on serotonin systems which interact with
lsd and things like that even read some
books by uh
uh the uh notable timothy leary and um
you know that really sort of uh sparked
my curiosity and so from there i did
actually go to richard axel's lab in new
york to work on the molecular biology of
neurotransmitter systems serotonin
receptors etc
uh once i started my own lab i sort of
carried over that interest but i got
interested in sensory systems yeah and
uh and in particular understanding the
re where this all comes together is
understanding
how we sense pain
and what are the molecular mechanisms
that allow us to detect painful stimuli
so of course as you know that's an
important component of the somatosensory
system or what we colloquially refer to
as touch
uh
you know aside from light touch
uh temperature sensation there's pain
which in some ways is kind of a enhanced
version of those other modalities but it
also includes sensitivity to things like
chemical irritants both in the
environment
and and and and chemical agents
so-called algogenic agents things that
enhance our sense of pain that are
produced from within when we have
inflammation yeah and you know we really
got interested in my lab in
understanding what the basis for that
kind of sensation
uh was and uh you know touch was at that
time sort of the the lagging
sensory system about which we knew the
least compared to vision or faction
hearing etc so uh it was kind of a is
that because is that because the the
other senses you know sight and sound
and taste they're localized in the body
so does that sort of exactly our
attention
simpler problem in some sense
in a way i mean they're all complex
problems and i don't want to minimize
the beautiful work
and the history of those fields they're
really momentous but um
in part yes you know if you want to
people like george wald and others if
they want to understand when they want
to understand what the proteins are in
the retina that uh that respond to
photons they go to the slaughterhouse
and get a bucket of cow eyeballs and do
some great bucket biochemistry on that
uh the other thing too is that you know
there was some
based on on those studies and then um
you know biochemical and pharmacological
studies there were some hints and
insights into what types of molecules
might be involved for example an
olfaction
that allowed richard axel and linda buck
to do their amazing studies and have a
directed approach to use pcr methods to
look for a particular class of proteins
namely g protein-coupled receptors that
they thought would be
the key odorant receptors which turned
out to be the case you know in touch
sensation and pain
we really didn't have that kind of
insight to understand
what class of molecules might be
involved right uh and so the search was
much more open-ended and you know when
you think about vision and olfaction
they're very complex but they you
basically use the same platform and the
same is true for taste in a way
to some degree they use the same
platform of molecular signaling devices
mostly based on g protein coupled
receptors
um in in the studies that we've done and
that artem has done that's
turned out to be important but not
directly in terms of detecting stimuli
so so there weren't as many genetic
or biochemical leads and that really
meant that we had to take approaches
that were different so without a bucket
of cow eyeballs
i gather you went to a different
stimulant namely chili peppers right is
that right that's the direction you want
so just uh what what
what led you to that my specific
question also is
if you're interested in in understanding
heat which i gather was part of the
motivation
i would have thought naively that you
would have gone like for a flame or for
you know
why go for a chemical that in some sense
seems to emulate
but not yield higher kinetic energy
thinking as a flat footed physicist
that's what we mean by
yeah yeah
yeah exactly well
um you know dealing with me with
physical stimuli is a little bit more
difficult in the laboratory
um
and so what we did was to convert a
physical problem to a chemical problem
by finding and and and the and the
chemicals that we have used which we'll
talk about in a sec second are actually
quite potent and strong and stimulate
and you know to be to be honest we did
not know when we initiated this that so
we used as you know capsaicin the
pungent ingredient from chili peppers to
find the first of these ion channels and
at the outset we did not really know
that this would lead us to a molecular
device that was central to detecting
heat i mean in retrospect it sounds so
cogently beautiful
uh there's this sort of you know
uh merging of of of of uh sensory
experiences and of course we described
chili peppers as being hot so in
retrospect it's sort of obvious but
uh you know was it was uh equally
possible and turns out to be true in
some ways that this receptor
that's uh that sees capsaicin could also
be activated by a chemical agent and
there are there are many for example
endogenous lipid like compact lipid
derived messengers uh bioactive lipids
that do mimic the actions of capsaicin
by binding to the same site the
so-called vandaloid site
and um and that's an important uh
stimulus to this channel as well but
that could have occurred and and been
important for the generation of pain
responses even if this channel were not
itself heat sensitive so
uh
you know we really realized that this
channel was a very heat sensitive
channel after we we cloned it but the
reason that we started with capsaicin
really has to do with history in the
field and that is as well as you know
natural products and um
and uh and folk medicine you know we all
know of course we experience this hot
burning sensation and that's intriguing
enough but um
people uh before us uh mostly uh folks
like yansko gabor in in hungary in the
60s and 70s had shown that capsaicin is
a very potent excitatory agent for a
subset of sensory neurons that were
believed to play a role in pain
sensation these so-called nociceptors
and so for many years capsaicin's
sensitivity to capsaicin became sort of
a functional hallmark for those neurons
so there had been a goal in fact i would
call it sort of a holy grail of of
understanding how capsaicin works in the
pain field you know many years before we
became involved nice area i think and
and what was lacking was you know real
molecular and mechanistic insight into
how capsaicin worked so how did you do
how did you how did you approach that i
mean so you've got um
[Music]
well uh again you know there wasn't much
to work on and we
we did sort of take a flyer on this but
what we did was we used
um what's called heterologous gene
expression methods to see if we could
take an ordinary fibroblast like cell in
culture it's actually a kidney derived
cell line called hek293 and see if we
could render it sensitive to capsaicin
by transferring in a gene or genes
that would uh
you know provide the apparatus that was
necessary for this
and so there are several unknowns one is
that using this technique if it's more
than one gene that's involved your
chances of finding it decrease
substantially exponentially so we were
we were lucky that there was one gene
and in fact for autumn uh that was lucky
in some regards too that one gene
product was enough were you worried
recapitulate mechanical sensation yeah
you're always worried in science
there's always some risk involved yeah i
mean because there's yeah some sense
it's a bit of a shot in the dark to
assume that it's a single gene that
could
yield this sensitivity to this true
feminine right yeah we were worried um
but you know there had been other things
that we had that i had worked on in the
past when i was a post-doc where we i
took a similar uh you know risk in it
and it worked but yes you're right you
know someone could have worked on this
for quite a while we did have some
backup plans to try and figure out how
we might approach this if it turned out
to be a multi-gene complex
but that would have been much more
difficult so we got would you have taken
on that project i assume you're already
tenured and and had security is this the
kind of project that you would have
taken on say as a as a graduate student
or postdoc or yes absolutely
and in fact um i encouraged mike
katarina who was the fellow in my lab to
do this and i said this is going to be
risky but if it works it's going to be
fantastic and i would have not
encouraged him to do that if i myself
were not willing to do it when i was at
his stage so uh and you know the thing
is that we knew that we would devote a
certain amount of time to this
and um if it didn't work you know you'd
have to pull your head up and say okay
what's next and i think that's just part
of doing science you know yeah you take
some risks most of what you do is going
to fail you know that going forward yeah
and um you know if it gets you out of
bed in the morning and it's the most
exciting thing that you can think about
doing that's what you want to do if one
gene had not
seemed to work would you have continued
to
enlarge the universes a universe of
genes you considered or would you have
gone to two to try to find the right
combination or
like you say have sort of turned to
something else yeah so so the way we did
this and kind of the uh occam's razor
this is at
you don't just look at one gene at a
time when you do this you make a a gene
library what we call a cdna library at
the time and you introduce genes into
these you know fibroblasts and culture
on mass in bulk
and so we did this so that at any given
any given what we call transfection
that's introducing the dna to the cells
in the dish
that collection of cdna is numbered in
about 10 000.
but you know you have to kind of adjust
this so that
it's big enough so that the probability
that your gene of interest or genes of
interest will be in there
um are uh
is is
you know significant but not so big that
things are diluted out so much that the
sensitivity drops so that you can't see
it so there comes a tipping point there
but if you make the pool large enough
and then and the gene is expressed at a
high enough level there is the chance
that even if there were multiple genes
that you could introduce them rarely but
into one cell simultaneously
and and there are examples of that
through different techniques and not
just cdna but genomic expression this is
for example how
the recombinase recombinases for uh
for um immunoglobulins the so-called rag
genes were identified by marianne
ottinger and david baltimore's lab that
that's a that's a two gene
affair to protein affair and and she got
fortunate in that those genes were
linked together closely on the
chromosome and so when she did what we
call whole genome transfection which
would have been another way to do this
she was lucky enough to get both of
those proteins in one cell
simultaneously but you know you need
luck for that and the chances go down
substantially but you know
we got lucky and uh and we and the other
question was how do you detect this
event
you know what's the best way to do that
because it's all in the assay right like
everything else in in in biology it's
all in the assay and um and there had
been uh indications in the literature
but a lot of this stuff had been
published actually in abstracts uh from
meetings to say the british
pharmacological society of people who
had patch clamp
done electrophysiological recordings
from sensory neurons
and had evidence that when you put
capsaicin on these cells uh you know you
increase ion flow across the membrane
which is what you'd expect and that this
included the entry of calcium into the
cell so at the time
uh there were um systems albeit crude
compared to today to be able to leverage
uh the beautiful reagents of a another
nobel laureate the um the late uh roger
chen
that um are dyes that bind calcium and
then fluoresce in the cell
uh when calcium levels go up and what
this meant is we could load these cells
in a dish with these with this calcium
so-called calcium indicator called fura
and then
use a microscopic assay to look for
cells that that glowed right when you
put capsaicin on them as a as a
measurement of calcium influx and
so that was another risk in that you
know we were hoping that uh this was
actually the case that we would see
permeability of the membrane to calcium
ions on a rather fast time scale that
would allow us to detect this
uh and so what mike did when he was in
my lab was he sort of mocked up these
situations with receptors that were
known to increase calcium in the cell to
see how big our pool could be what the
sensitivity was our system at the time
was was rather low
uh sensitivity so we really had to kind
of be careful about that
and then once we had those things in
place
you know the receptor actually the clone
for the capstan receptor fell out in
fairly short order it only took about a
month of screening right and and so is
it clear in retrospect the issue that
you said that perhaps you should have
thought of at the outset
why is the response to this particular
chemical capsaicin and chilean peppers
why is it the same as the response to
molecules moving more quickly heat
why are they conflated well that's an
accident of evolution right so the chili
pepper uh makes this compound
you know just
presumably it's been selected for
because it um averts
predatory mammals like squirrels and
deer
and um
and and uh and and how does it do that
it's evolved through the accident of
convergent evolution to act on a
receptor that we have in our bodies that
we use for something else
um and so uh conveniently for the pepper
plant it's figured out in evolutionary
time how to make this thing to generate
pain
of course we as humans like to do things
that
you know
hurt us in some ways like smoke
cigarettes and drink alcohol so we like
to consume chili peppers and um
and uh you know that so this receptor in
mammals has evolved a pocket
that binds this uh you know pungent
agent and why is the pocket there in our
channel that's what one might ask and i
think the reason is that that pocket
exists to appreciate and bind endogenous
inflammatory agents like bioactive
lipids that alter the sensitivity of the
channel to heat and thereby contribute
to
pain hypersensitivity when there's
injury
now interestingly not all animals have
that and there's a really interesting
phenomenon of what uh this this uh
ecologist jonathan tewksbury has called
directed deterrence and and as far as i
know this situation is sort of the main
example of that and that is that birds
can eat chili peppers with impunity they
are very have very low sensitivity to
capsaicin and presumably yeah and well
then how does the body know
to
respond really negatively when your
hands in a flame
and not to respond so negatively if
you've just done too much of the hot
sauce at you know at those tacos you
know how does it distinguish oh well
sometimes we do respond negatively it's
sort of you know there's a lot of
behavior involved in pain
and pain sensation
and some of it's anticipatory and
knowing what you're getting yourself
into right
um
and we learn through experience right so
but you can get yourself into trouble of
course with eating you know too much too
much especially
in your gi tract or
you know if you chop a hot chili pepper
and then stick your finger in your eye
oh that's not an enjoyable experience or
or breathe it in which i did
exactly by mistake it was quite yes yeah
and you can you can go into basically
what's like uh you know
uh a a severe what's almost like an
allergic reaction in your lung right and
um and so
um i think it depends on context right
and and this is why we can also
distinguish between when we'd actually
eat the chili pepper or touched
something hot because there's context to
the experience right right and i think
that plays a big role in any sensory
system particularly in pain sensation so
how close would you say we are or maybe
we're actually there to really being
able to describe you know right down at
the level of fundamental particles you
know electrons protons neutrons even
quarks and the fundamental forces in
this case the electromagnetic force
being the dominant one to what extent
can we actually give a first principles
fundamental explanation of what happens
when we touch something that's hot or
eat something that's spicy
yeah well we're definitely much closer
i'd say one of the things that's brought
us a lot closer to that is being able to
see these channels in atomic
three-dimensional space so
you know using these methods like
uh predominantly electron cryo
microscopy which is kind of
revolutionized structural biology
we can see these channels including the
piezo channels that are worked on and
the trip channels we've worked on
in near atomic resolution yeah and um
and that tells us at least how these
channels change their shape
and open up to allow ions to go through
particularly
for chip channels in the context of
chemical activators like capsaicin
because that's just an easier thing to
do
than to see changes that are induced by
heat but recent studies
by a number of labs including um sasha
sobel fc's live in columbia have now
been trying to combine these techniques
to look at changes that actually happen
in these channels when they're subjected
to uh changes in ambient temperature
and that will tell us really about
how the channel opens and closes as a
function of ambient temperature and and
then is it a single channel that is
tempered that works for all temperatures
or do different things no so so the
other natural product we've taken
advantage of is uh is one from the mint
plant called menthol which we all know
is a nice cooling agent
anyone who's had a mint julep or uh you
know
shoot some spearmint gum and um and
that's kind of the flip side of this
story right it's uh we conflate that
with a cold sensation or a cooling
sensation
and again you know
that realization is based not only on
our molecular findings but on very early
physiologic studies by some pioneers
like hensel and zodderman who were
swedish physiologists and showed that um
putting menthol on a sensory neurons of
the cat tongue
uh greatly modulates their sensitivity
to cold
and so in their original paper they they
said oh this suggests that there's some
you know biochemical device that is uh
you know
appreciates these two things and and the
cloning of that by you know show bears
that out that trip m8 a a distant uh
well a relative a molecular cousin of
trip v1 also a chip channel is a
receptor for both cold and menthol so is
that just another evolutionary
coincidence that both hot and cold have
kind of a homologous version yeah
chemical stimulants
that's a great question
it didn't have to be that way
you know
but presumably these trip channels so
many of these trip channels we don't
know if they actually serve a role as
chem as thermal thermal sensors in vivo
but many of them are thermally sensitive
and so i think that that's a
characteristic of these molecules that's
been carried through at least some
component of this gene family
and in some cases like chip v1 and trip
m8
that um
that describes a very important
physiological role that they play so
when you look at these trip channels
like in retrospect would you say that
things are
well designed well engineered i mean if
you could do this from scratch would you
have a much more streamlined approach or
did evolution sort of hit it out of the
park on this one
man that's a very that's a complex
question
uh
only mother nature knows the answer to
those questions yeah well i mean you can
always make things simpler right you
know in some ways what i was going to
say is that this this um
this situation with the bird channel
so
so birds are very insensitive to
capsaicin that's how we first stand
you're my lab maps the site for
capsaicin binding by comparing birds to
mammals namely the insensitive intensive
channel so you know there's an example
where you have a channel that's still
temperature sensitive
but
you know it doesn't respond as well to
vandaloid compounds and presumably
that's because it hasn't the mammalian
channel has evolved to be more
sophisticated to be able to appreciate
other things like these bioactive lipids
that fit in that pocket so
uh you know i guess there are always
simpler forms of these channels
um you know the channel itself is
it's not a huge complex device you know
it's a it's a tetrameric protein that
sits in the membrane it basically forms
a donut
uh we are wondering everyone's wondering
are there other proteins that associate
within the cytoplasm and we and other
people have always been looking for
these things but in its root form and a
form that where you can recapitulate of
most of its known functions
in
an artificial situation like a
transfected mammalian cell all you need
is this one gene product that forms a
tetrameric channel so i would say in
some ways that in and of itself compared
to say some complex transcription or
replication complex
uh
is a fairly simple little device yeah
it's neat it's compact
and somehow it converts this energy very
efficiently into a change in electrical
current is it conceivable that another
uh life form on the planet that you
haven't yet studied in detail
may have realized that simpler version
yes it's possible you know
um mechanic sensation and other senses
are not always carried through in terms
of molecular design through evolution so
invertebrates often uh
um or lower and lower eukaryotes like
yeast often find different solutions to
these same problems
and in invertebrate organisms there is
some carryover this trip a1 channel
which is mostly a chemical sensor in our
bodies this is the wasabi receptor as we
call it uh you know it plays a role as a
heat sensor in some organisms like
fruit flies
uh
and um
and um
and so there are there there are
similarities but there there are also
you know maybe different molecules
cyclic nucleotidated channels may play a
role in temperature sensation it flies
so there are different ways to skin a
cat as they say and
and i think in many sensory systems
uh there are similarities but there are
there are differences and you know there
are different many different sort of
mechanical sensors in
in uh in uh invertebrate organisms
uh
you know nom c channels which are more
of the member of the trip channel family
than piezo channel so there are
different
ways to solve this problem and um and
while we all like to look for continuity
through evolution it doesn't mean that
uh that's always the case right
so when life begins to finally settle
down in a year or two or three from
the excitement of the nobel prize where
where do you see your research program
going
you know we're still so fascinated with
this problem i mean pain pain sensation
is such a complex phenomenon
and there's still so much to do and
there's so much to do
at the level of therapeutics which isn't
you know our direct domain in terms of
drug design or anything but i think that
will still benefit tremendously from
just basic
research because we still don't
understand all the molecules involved
we you know us and and and a big unknown
still is sort of the
you know the circuitry
the wiring diagram that takes the
initial signal from the primary afferent
nociceptor to the spinal cord uh and
then to many areas of the brain
uh and aspects of that that relate to
cognition
you know
not only just identification of the
stimulus and where it's occurring on
your body but cognitive aspects of it is
still
so um
you know there's still so much to know
uh so we're continuing to work on that
uh you know as a biochemist at heart i'm
still fascinated by the structure of
these proteins and what they do
and um and so you know with my friend
ifon chang at ucsf we're still really
involved in looking at the molecular
structure these of these molecules i
think that's going to be really
important for drug design there are some
some impediments to using some of these
antagonists for these channels which we
can talk about but um
so we still need some further research
and then you know the other part of my
lab my lab's always small but the two or
three people who were four people who
are really interested in physiology you
know we're looking at models of
different
pain uh
scenarios because you know we use this
one-term pain but it's like cancer sure
you know it describes a whole panoply of
different chronic disorders like
migraine pains different from you know
inflammatory bowel syndrome pain etc and
so we're looking at different models
we're doing a lot of work actually now
and trying to figure out mechanisms that
are involved in gi pain i think which
affects a lot of people because i think
you need to know the specifics about
those pathways and what types of
molecules and those receptor cell types
are involved
because targeting them with drugs will
probably be different for different
types of pain we know that and
you know unless we know something about
those details it's hard to really
understand what to do do you think this
research will ultimately be key
to addressing the big unknown which is
why do we have these inner sensations of
these experiences i mean the body could
just be completely mechanistic you know
you touch a flame and the hand pulls
away and it's just mechanism without
deep sensation
where does the inner world of sensation
and qualia come from
yeah so you're asking why isn't it all
just a spinal reflex yeah
well um you know i think this relates to
all sensory systems but yeah pain you
wonder why in particular do we need to
have a cognitive component of pain
well some of it is a memory component
because that's how we learn
and we need to you know white you know
if if if pain protected us as a purely
as a reflex
you would injure yourself again and
again right touch the hot stove you're
going to get burned even if you pull
your hand away but it's better to learn
so having of course a memory and a
learning mechanism is critical
um and you know there are emotional
components to this um i think that's uh
this anticipatory
stuff you know and that's both good and
bad i i presume
but
why we have those is uh
probably a better question for
psychologists but um i think part of it
is is um is so that we have an emotional
memory of these things so that we can uh
protect ourselves and
and and protect our children to let them
know don't do this don't do that you
know at the most basic level and of
course
there are more complex reasons for that
but you know that's also part and parcel
of why treating chronic pain is a
difficult thing because there's a there
is a big emotional component to it
and um
and uh and it becomes a very complex
thing for physicians to deal with yep
one final question you uh earlier noted
that you went into this knowing that it
was a high
risk endeavor and clearly it was one
that's also a high reward endeavor as we
see right now
in giving advice to young scientists who
are up and coming
how
do you suggest they negotiate that bout
yeah um you know you have to be
practical at some level you can't spread
yourself too thin and you know you do
have to be productive
but you know i i guess um
maybe now this sounds gratuitous
sounding it's better saying this but i
think i've always kind of felt this way
and and hopefully acted in this way but
you know
doing science is a lot of work
uh like anything that you're kind of
passionate about
um and i think it's sort of a shame to
do that on something that you're not
really excited about
so you gotta kind of work on what gets
you up out of bed in the morning you
know if you're going to go to the lab
and say well i have to do this because i
said i was going to do this in my grant
and i'm not really interested in it and
it's i'm not really inspiring people in
my lab to do this because i'm finding it
to be drawl
and we all come across those situations
because
you know grant writing sort of in some
ways
makes you do that a little bit in terms
of what you but you know
one one of the wonderful things i'd say
about at least in the us you know public
funding through the nih is that you know
you write a grant and you'll be funded
for that grant based in part on what
you've done what you've proposed in a
way
but you know they're rather forgiving
and understanding if you don't do
exactly what you said you're going to do
and instead do something that's really
exciting and important i've never seen
anybody
get turned down you know in their
renewal because they did something
fantastic and so i think that you know
young people should remember that and
that they should strive to do something
that they're really excited about and
that they know
will change the landscape of the field
that they're in
you know so
doing the same thing over and over and
over again and moving the field
incrementally uh is
is is
shouldn't be the goal
and and we you know but but it's a
balancing act and you have to do some
things that follow up on what you've
done because sometimes those things
actually turn out to be you know quite
interesting even though you might not
expect it and you do have to sort of
develop a body of expertise
so that you can really you know ratchet
up your game and approach things at a
better and better level but at the same
time you know you can carve off a piece
of your resources in a and some of your
time if you have people in your lab who
are willing to jump off the cliff with
you and take a flyer
uh because that you know that
won't kill you if it doesn't work um but
to always have something that really
gets you excited kind of you know on the
shelf that you can pull down and say you
know i'm going to start making inroads
into this and see how it goes and then
if it's exciting and it really expands
you know you can expand your research
into that turn the ship a little bit
slowly and go for that so that's kind of
always been my approach yeah and um and
that keeps me and the people in the lab
you know really enthusiastic about stuff
yeah well it's hugely important advice
so thank you for that and
congratulations again
on this well-deserved recognition of the
profoundly important work that you and
your laboratory have been doing and
thanks so much for spending this time
with us let us now turn
to artem potapudian who shared the nobel
prize in physiology or medicine with
david julius who joins us now from his
office in la jolla california welcome
art m
oh thank you chris let's be here
congratulations this is a really
spectacular
recognition i can't imagine how exciting
it is i mean how
like did you get that famous
early morning telephone call is that how
you got the word
kind of it was actually um
ended up being a very interesting story
because uh like many of us uh have um
silenced our phone into do not disturb
in the middle of the night and i had
that and apparently i missed four calls
from stockholm wait are you saying on
the nobel prize announcement morning you
didn't think to maybe turn it on was it
so
out of your mind as a possibility
uh uh honestly yes especially this year
but um
uh i think um i'm i'm gonna be honest
and say if you win other prizes like the
kavli people talk about this of course
but it's one thing to say you might be
considered there's probably a lot of
people think they are considered another
thing to actually get the phone call and
it was it was a complete shock honestly
um
and uh anyway so i did i did miss four
phone calls
and then somehow they had found my 94
year old
father's number who lives in los angeles
oh really he has a he has a landline so
they called him
and he was he was very angry at them
first of why they're bothering him
oh what time is it what time is it for
him like after 2 a.m
2 20 something like that
and um they didn't tell him because they
can't tell anyone about me they just
wanted my number oh my god and and he
did he did give it to them but as soon
as he hung up he called me
and i guess this do not disturb kind of
calls
um do not apply to people who are
favorites on your phone so he was able
to get through
and and tell me so it ended up being a
super special moment because i heard it
from my 94 year old dad and that's
really
that is fantastic that is absolutely
fantastic and i mean
do you feel that
you've been in the running for a while
or is it just sort of one of those
things that you just keep on a back
burner and you don't let it distract you
yeah i think it's it's the latter i i
think uh it's a healthy thing not to
listen to those kind of rumors and uh
again honestly i thought it's a
possibility at some point but to me this
came a bit earlier than i
anticipated and that's why it was kind
of a bigger shock yeah well
congratulations again that now you
if i understand i i believe you grew up
in in lebanon is that is that correct
that's true so i yeah
i mean i mean i'm armenian origin so i
grew up speaking armenia as my first
language but i i did grew up in lebanon
i came to
us when i was 18.
um i haven't verified this but from what
people have told me um this is the first
nobel affiliation with lebanon or
armenia so
both those countries who have had a
tough year with the economy and the war
i hear this is this is a nice little bit
of cheer
uh and i'm and i'm and i'm proud to
represent that and of course i'm a u.s
citizen now so
um very very grateful for for this
country as well yeah that hugely so but
i mean
being a role model
for kids anywhere in the world
especially
in a place where life can be so
difficult this must be very gratifying
sense that kids can look up to you and
imagine that one day
they might be in a position like you're
in
it is an incredible honor and
responsibility the number of emails i've
gotten from people
saying you know i have a similar
background and you know they're like 20
year olds and thinking that this this is
a possibility
it really brings chills i mean it's a
it's a it's really it's really something
and i have to get used to that role
uh and embrace it hopefully but it is it
is very interesting indeed well i think
that's one of the most powerful thing
about these awards that are recognized
across the globe the role that it puts
you in and yes i
it is an enormous responsibility but the
impact that you can have of course is
commensurate with that
if we can turn maybe to some of the
actual
science that is responsible my favorite
subject absolutely so we we just spoke
with david julius about his work in
giving insight into how the body senses
heat and cold understanding molecular
mechanisms you too your work also
focused on how the body senses the world
but from the standpoint of touch and
pressure is that is that a correct
description of where your focus has been
so the last 10 years the focus has been
more on pressure sensing
um and um so yeah the sense of touch and
pain is the is the main entry point of
our interest
however
identifying these molecules that we did
that sense pressure and turn it into
chemical signal that cells understand
has also led us into
uh novel areas some expected some not
which includes
regulating blood pressure
bladder control every time you feel like
you have to go to restroom these
molecules are involved
and many other new areas stomach
fullness we're studying but also in
immune cells and red blood cells all
seem to be
in addition to sensing chemicals which
is the the main way of cells to
communicate is through chemicals whether
it's hormones or neurotransmitters like
dopamine cells no chemicals and they
know how to communicate but this is kind
of
the what the price recognized i think is
that there's also this whole whole other
sensory system in the body that
focuses on sensing physical forces such
as pressure and temperature and
converting them to to chemical signal
that the cell understands and so what
was the what was the state of the art
say prior to the work that you guys
began to do is this a problem that
people have focused upon for a while or
did it begin with your work
um so um
jim hutzpat professor rockefeller
decades ago
identified that there must be this group
of proteins that we study called ion
channels which are very fast signaling
molecules they do only one thing they're
either closed or they're open when the
open ions go through so very simple
so he showed that these type of channels
exist and must explain mechanosensing
so what was not known is what are these
molecules and with the human and and
animal genetics that that now exist
finding the molecule is not just saying
haha i found the molecule which is
interesting in itself but it really
opens the door because you can sequence
humans and see who doesn't have a normal
copy a mutant copy you can make genetic
mutations in animal models and show that
oh this protein is required for sensing
touch or pain or bladder control
and so what david's lab did for
temperature
as well as us and pressure sensing is
identify these proteins these gene
products uh and study them in vivo what
we call it which is in the animal
and how i i mean i understand the basic
strategy that you're describing but
how do you go about doing that i mean
there's so many genes so many
possibilities how do you even narrow it
down to begin to focus in on what might
be the right one for coding that program
i mean you know you know this very well
brian that the scientists always think
how reductionist of an approach i can
take to answer the question at hand
if you go to reductionist you're asking
irrelevant questions if you make it too
complex you'll never get an answer and
so for us it was just the idea to say
that instead of studying these tiny
neurons with very heterogeneous and
difficult to manipulate
let's find a cell that grows in a test
tube which responds to mechanical force
and then find it there so that actually
assumption was the key to our success
because we reduced the problem to
finding it in a in a in a test tube in a
dish instead of in the body and once we
found that cell uh it was a matter of
deleting one gene at a time that we
thought was a candidate and seeing if
this activity is still there and when
it's not we know ah this is a candidate
and
how many genes did you have to go
through i mean so for for this uh my
postdoctoral fellow bertrand coast who
runs his own lab now uh had to look at
72 candidates before he hit the correct
one and this was not an easy task each
candidate you know this is not a you ask
and you get an answer immediately it's a
two-day experiment for each one so you
know
literally he spent a whole year of
getting negative data
and then finally the
the the day that he tested candidate
number 72 was was the correct one so it
was a it was a great day now as with
david julius that way you describe it
suggests that you were making an
assumption that it was a single gene
that would be responsible is there a
chance that that assumption could have
failed and you would have gone through
all of the possibilities all 72 or
whatever and none of them would have
yielded the positive
result
first i should say we had 300 candidates
okay so we stopped at 72 because it was
the correct one right one yeah but
absolutely
it could have been a wrong
assumption but the nice thing about loss
of function the leading experiments
is that
let's say it was a protein that's made
out of five genes
if every single one is somewhat required
for it we would have seen it
so we did we weren't assuming that it's
a single gene we were just assuming that
there is a subunit that is essential
for the activity now that's a good point
right so unless it were the case that
there was some redundancy in the system
that would i guess that's what it foiled
you right
i wouldn't be talking to you right now
right right exactly uh but that's uh
that's great so so then you find the the
gene the gene codes for some
protein does that then end the story or
do you then need to actually work out
the detailed mechanism
at the molecular level for sensing
pressure it's almost the beginning of
the story because you can imagine a lot
of ways something x is required for y
that doesn't mean x is doing y right and
so the first thing we did actually make
the protein in a naive cell and if you
put it there it makes the cell
mechanosensitive so now you have
necessary and sufficient so if you knock
it out you don't see the activity you
put it somewhere naive and there is an
activity
after that we've done structural studies
where we know what it looks like in the
in the in the membrane uh i mean do you
have 3d 3d
models or images oh yeah
actually you can actually do a show
show-and-tell for us yeah it is a
fascinating molecule so this is what it
looks like
it is um
i'm like i'm disoriented yep you're good
you're good right there each each
each subunit it comes together as a copy
of three of the same gene so each of
them is a different color here and if i
show you the bottom
so this is the membrane it actually
bends the membrane it sits in a bent
part of the membrane and it has 38
transmembrane domains these are these
little helices that go up and down the
lipid bilayer
and so it's extended like this and when
membrane stretches this will open up and
ions start going to right in the middle
there
and the stretching is from some external
pressure that the
membrane every time every time you do
this you're indenting the membrane is
being stretched and it opens up a little
bit let's ions come in
and we can do this without the cell you
can put it in the bilayer and it still
works so we know it's the sensor got it
and and
is it the same
for
all
living systems that have this capacity
to sense pressure or does it does it i
mean there are there are other
mechanosensors but the piezos the one
that we found are remarkably conserved
we just actually had a paper
showing that the exact homolog of this
protein
is in plants
it's expressed in the roots and what
they do there is they sense how hard the
surface is so they can navigate
through the different hardness of the of
the soil and so just imagine that for a
while that evolution has created the
same protein for us to sense touch and
for plant roots to navigate through the
soil i find that quite quite remarkable
it is remarkable you know one thing as
dave and i'm wondering what your
perspective on it is now that you have a
a clear sense of
the mechanism by which we sense touch
pressure
would you consider it
to be an efficient engineering solution
to that particular engineering challenge
i mean did evolution do a good job at
finding this way of doing it or now that
you see it you're like oh if only
evolution would have found this solution
how much easier it would have been
there's lots of things we don't know but
it does seem like a very efficient
pressure sensor i actually call it
professional mechanosensor because like
many other proteins do lots of things
they kind of are poly modal they they
specialize through a little bit of this
little bit of that
all these years that we're studying this
this is just
the structure everything about it is
evolved to sense tension
um and it seems to do pretty good job at
it
one of the evolutionary cost is that
it's very large it's one of the largest
ion channels identified and does it have
to be this big
those are questions that we still ask
but the fact that both in plants and
human it's approximately the same size
very large tells you that it somehow
needs to be that large
and and is it the same mechanism
regardless of the strength of the
pressure i mean is there some kind of
non-linear quality where when the
pressure builds up or the you know the
the force is greater that something else
kicks in or is it just the same all the
way through
so these are things we don't know yet um
brian i think the
uh it was a big surprise to people in
the field because when they record from
um for example muscle afferents or skin
afferents or or bladder afferents um
they have seen very different qualities
of recordings quantitatively they could
be rapidly adapting they could be firing
the whole time you put pressure on and
so people had assumed that there's going
to be
tens of pressure sensors each
specialized for a different type of
sensory mechanism but the more and more
we're finding that this piezo2 accounts
for many of these i don't want to say oh
there's still some that are not
accounted for
but it seems to be somehow modulated in
each of specific conditions
to
have slightly different properties
and lots of this is anatomy because if
you look at the anatomy of the neuronal
endings
that sense these it's fascinating so you
have for example something called
pecinian corpuscle which is a neural
ending that comes in and there's the
structures onion-like layers surrounding
it which almost seemed like amplify
mechanical signals so i think you take
this molecule and put it in a very
specific condition very specific
anatomical environment and you get
slightly different outputs and is it the
same i mean if if the pressure turns
into like cutting if you cut your finger
is it same exact mechanism or
is it does that differ by virtue of it
it's actually quite different so
there are individuals who
do not have piezo2 and they do not sense
touch they do not have proprioception
this ability to close your eyes and
touch your nose but acute pain is there
so if they cut themselves hammer hits
their finger they feel this
and this is what i'm saying there's
another mechanosensor there that we have
not yet identified ah that's that is
that is fascinating and so
what about the phenomenon
where
you know this phantom limb phenomenon
where you know people lose a limb but
they still
feel like it itches or there's pressure
on it does does your work of insight
into that
um
a little bit so pain is very complex as
i've said before
pain is an emotion right and so in the
field we dissociate pain
which is a feeling and emotion from what
we call nociception which is the
transduction of
noxious stimuli into electrical signals
and so what you're describing is
actually is a neuropathy in a way where
in the absence of stimulation the finger
is not even there the pain is still
there so one of the
data points that suggests that this
peripheral stuff is related to that
let's say you don't have hand and you
give anesthetic at the nub of where it
is this neuropathic pain phantom limb
goes away
while the anesthetic is there which
means that it is in the brain but it's
modulated from the periphery so it's
amplified misinterpreted maybe but it is
still coming from there because the
nerve is cut
you know we often think about
how the body
responds to stimuli in the external
world you know someone hits you hard and
you respond to that eyes open wide heart
beats fast there's all sorts of bodily
responses that influence your
interpretation of what that touch that
pressure was
is that non-linear could it be the case
that you can
simulate a certain kind of reaction by
simply getting the heart beating faster
and there's no actual danger in the
world but yet the body will respond to
some sort of touch in a way that it
would have if it were actually in danger
is there that non-linear interplay
feedback mechanism
absolutely i think
i actually believe that your nervous
system
fools you into thinking
you feel this and that and so it is
gathering this information about
temperature and pressure but during
evolution it's evolved to realize that
the best way to tell you
how to react is to make you feel a
certain way but it's not necessarily
what you're feeling exactly in that area
yeah yeah i give the idea of urination
um
without getting into too much details
when you have to go you feel it in a
certain place
but the real mechanical force is in your
bladder you're not feeling your bladder
you're feeling it somewhere else that's
i think a very good example of how your
brain wants you to go to the restroom
and makes you feel in a way that
would want you to do that that's not
necessarily what you're feeling so it's
all a simulation in a way
of of of of what the brain thinks you
should do and so what you're feeling is
not necessary it's a it's a
representation of the external world
it's not a photograph of the external
world yeah so that naturally takes me to
a question i also asked
david julius's question but wonder if
you have any thoughts on it
it's one thing to understand
the deep mechanisms of how we sense heat
or cold or pressure or touch
it's another thing to understand how it
is that those channels those mechanisms
yield the inner sensations that we feel
about those things because again it
could have just been a completely
mechanical set of processes that did not
yield any inner sensation any inner
qualia
do you think that the insights that that
you and and david and your groups have
provided will they
yield ultimately a deeper insight into
why we experience these external stimuli
in the way that we do
i think so it's going to take a little
bit of time but absolutely i think
the way i think about it is they're
they're a handle on the question
if you don't have this how are you even
going to ask that question um i've
often compared to what we do is it's
it's a handle door to the room if you
don't know where it is and it's a dark
room you're never going to find out but
this is a marker that we can hold on we
have experiments we can say that you can
activate this and see what happens in
the brain you activate a neighboring
thing see what happens you can block
this so we have tools now to start
asking those questions
of
the transduction all the way to the
perception i'm not saying it's
straightforward or be figured out in the
next year but without this it would be
very difficult to pursue that question
so you also began to describe some of
the work that you're doing now even
though the work that's being recognized
perhaps happened a little while ago what
is next where do you think all this is
headed
um so two things i mean one of it is
translational we want to see if
modulating these channels could have
benefits to neuropathic pain or other
forms of um clinically relevant
indications the other one is um i'm very
excited about and i feel like till now
we answered the question of
um
expected pressure sensing systems uh
we've
explained or in the process of
explaining
but what following these molecules are
telling us is this whole other area of
biology that we didn't suspect pressure
sensing is involved for example very
recently we've found that immune cells
actually actively sense pressure and
this affects how much they double up
other cells and if this process goes
wrong your blood iron levels get
modulated very strongly and so this
whole idea of immune cells phagocytosis
regulating blood iron levels
five years ago i would have not even
imagined pressure sensing has any role
in this whatsoever
and but that's the again the advantage
of finding these
molecules and pathways through human
genetics and mouse genetics we're just
discovering novel biology that depends
on pressure sensing that again was
completely ignored
and and
thinking more broadly now just to your
own career and obviously the success
that you
have and continue to enjoy
when you talk to younger scientists how
do you help them navigate the difficult
questions of do you work on something
that has an obvious answer you just have
to work it out
versus do you take you know this this
chance on something that could yield
nothing but
you know high risk high reward how do
you navigate that decision
i i think for me uh one thing very clear
is to obviously
ask a question that as important
as
transformative as possible
but with a huge butt
but that today we have the tools
either developed or close to developing
that can answer the question you know
many people have tried to answer the
consciousness question and nervous
system and we still don't really have
the tools to answer it and lots of
ex-nobel laureates have worked on it and
haven't made too much of an advance so i
think it's this uh overlap of how
transformative an open question you find
but overlap with that is it the right
time and the right place
with respect to the scientific tools we
have to address it and that's
my number one advice with respect to
what you're asking is to find that sweet
spot yeah
when you think back to being you know a
young child growing up in lebanon
what would you say
to the young kids who are now in the
shoes that you once occupied decades ago
regarding you know the possibilities of
of life a life and science and
the potentials that their future can
hold
dream big i guess and be open to
open to experiences and change don't be
scared of change
perfect advice
so again congratulations on this
well-deserved recognition
nobel prize in physiology or medicine
thank you so much for spending a little
time with us and the explanations really
certainly helped me and i know our
audience understand more fully
what you and david julius have done and
how
our bodies at a molecular level respond
to the stimuli of the external world so
thank you so much
thank you brian i just wanted to tell
you that i'm reading um your your
incredible book until the end of time
right now and talk about someone
explaining very difficult topics very
clearly uh really really enjoying it
well thank you really appreciate that
thanks a lot
all right
bye-bye bye
i want to thank our two guests today
david julius and arden potapudian new
nobel laureates and physiology or
medicine for joining us here today
and thank you too for joining us and
feel free to sign up to the world
science festival newsletter or subscribe
to the world science festival youtube
channel so you become aware of when our
programs go up online
and that is it today from the world
science festival in new york
[Music]
you